Sáng ngày 4.30, hôm 3.30, tại điểm thì trường Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông Trình Tuyên quanh
Mước vào một giữ văn khi thí tốt ngờ Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông Lần Hài
Đứ hình năm dần sáng lực lực ăn nình đã có mặt bảo đam
ăn ninh chất tự tại khu bực thay đến sáng dự văn mưu phút
Hau hết thí sinh đã có mặt tại điểm thí
Chất đó, tình đến trường ngày 4.30, có vá trăm 2.30, tí sinh để làm tụt tục giữ thí
Đặt chỉ tâm phải 1 tà phần chăm số thí sinh đủ điều kết
Bộ giống dụp ở đầu tạo cho biết sáng ngày có thêm ba thí sinh từ gió để làm tụt tục
Vá tham dự kí thí, điểm thí chơi Trung Hoặc Phổ Thông Trình Tuyên quanh Bộ
Chí mấy lắm phòng thí với một chăm bẩy lắm đường cạnh bộ, dân viên tham ra tụt
Chất đó, bẩy mấy người làm giống bộ chực tiếp tại điểm thí
Bộ giống dụp ở đầu tạo cũng thành lập đoàn giám sát của văn chỉ đạo thí
Các cuộc ra đối với công tắc có thí và chấm thí tại điểm này
Sau một người ước văn sáng ngày thí sinh sẽ văn thí môn tỏan vào châu cùng ngày
Châu gian nhau thí sinh bức bảo gí thí lại với tâm li khá toàn mai từ tin quan thành bà thí, phục bộ sẽ tưởng đại hông